je mehr geimpft sind umso freier werden
wir wieder sein lassen sie sich impfen
diesem appell sind bisher zu wenig
menschen gefolgt wenn wir die aktuellen
quoten nicht drastisch steigern dann
kann die aktuelle flotte welle im herbst
einen fulminanten show lauf nimmt ich
selbst habe mich gegen korona impfung
ich denke die impfung ist aktuell der
beste weg wie wir gemeinsam durch diese
pandemie kommen andere menschen sind
verunsichert und machen sich sorgen und
haben sich deswegen dass er nicht den
chronisten dass es nur noch mit lang
genug erforscht wurden ist es die freie
entscheidung des einzelnen oder eine
frage der solidarität
ich stelle fest dass die debatte dann
häufig sehr kontrovers noch sehr
emotional ist so als spalte sich unsere
gesellschaft in den geimpften und
ungeimpften der ton wird zunehmend gerät
muss man sagen auch die ränder der
befürworter wie der gegner werden
zunehmend militante ich war wissen wir
wer gemeinsam mit diesem konflikt wasser
umgehen kann
[Musik]
in einer mainzer weinbar treffe ich alex
bei den vorbereitungen für den abend ihn
hat die pandemie hart getroffen als der
lockdown kam hatte er gerade seine
ausbildung zum sommelier begonnen dafür
hatte er auf teilzeit reduziert dann kam
der doktor ich hab nicht arbeiten können
ich hab kurzarbeitergeld bekommen für
teilzeit dass man knapp 400 450 euro
davon haben sich gerade so die miete
bezahlen können und mussten kredit
aufnehmen für die zeit während der
ausbildung weil es sonst hat halt nicht
gereicht
und das muss ist jetzt abbezahlen
käme ist hart auf hart und die gastro
müsste wegen steigender corona zahlen
wieder schließen alex könnte sich das
nicht leisten
[Musik]
weil wir uns dadurch nicht umschulung
machen aber nicht mehr
alex hat sich schon vor einigen monaten
gegen korona impfen lassen er hat wenig
verständnis dafür dass manche diese
maßnahme strikt ablehnen wenn das setzen
was ich meine kinder oder kleinkinder
geht finde ich es gibt ja viele info mir
einfach gemacht werden müssen damit in
den kindergarten gehen dürften die
schule gehen müssen ja gewisse
impfungen gemacht werden und da macht
man das dann zum wohle des kindes auch
einfach gibt ja auch gewisse krankheiten
die wir dadurch besiegt haben über die
jahre und dass man jetzt auf einmal als
um eine selbst gemeint das muss ich
nicht und die impfung ist kann weiß gott
was auslösen und denke mir ja corona
kann noch viel schlimmer das auslösen
also ich find das ist auf jeden fall
eine frage der solidarität weil es eben
nicht nur um das eigene wohl geht
sondern das gemeinschafts wohl wir
kommen nur gemeinsam durch diese
pandemie deswegen lautet das ziel der
führenden wissenschaftler innen und
politiker innen herdenimmunität
das robert koch institut geht davon aus
dass dafür in deutschland von den zwölf
bis 59-jährigen 85 prozent sowie von den
über 60-jährigen 90 prozent vollständig
geimpft sein müssen geschafft haben wir
das noch nicht mittlerweile sind auch
expertinnen unsicher ob dieses ziel noch
rechtzeitig zu erreichen ist trotzdem
bei der eindämmung des virus hilft jede
impfung für diesen film will ich mit
jemandem sprechen der bewusst nicht
gegen korona geimpft ist und kein
querdenker oder
verschwörungstheoretikern ist ich suche
online und die resonanz ist groß doch
öffentlich darüber sprechen wollen die
wenigsten bei instagram schreibt mir
jemand für ein meinungsbild spreche ich
gerne mit dir aber öffentlich möchte ich
das nicht tut mir leid ich habe die
erfahrung gemacht dass meine
entscheidung von den meisten nicht
respektiert wird und es dann schnell
respekt ihr licht wird bei youtube
kommentiert ein user ungeimpfte werden
von der politik als menschen zweiter
klasse behandelt und die medien stellen
jedem der gegen die impfung ist als
völlig verblödeten querdenker ein
anderer schreibt das ist schon fast eine
straftat ist sich nicht nehmen zu lassen
das ist schon krass geworden in diesem
land ich merke wie emotional diese
debatte ist es scheint weniger um
wissenschaftliche fakten zu gehen als um
gefühle häufig ist die frage ob es
allein die entscheidung des einzelnen
ist oder eine verpflichtung zum wohle
der gemeinschaft
darüber spreche ich mit ethikerin ruth
baumann hölzle
sie sagt in dieser debatte läuft etwas
schief diese debatte ist hochmodern ihn
geworden zwischen guten und bösen die
anderen sind quasi zum gegner zum verein
stehe ich jetzt auf beiden seiten und
dass das erachte ich als eine immense
gefahr für unsere
gesellschaften weil das für die
militantes vorgehen noch einmal auf
beiden seiten wir hätten ihr die debatte
zwischen ungeimpft und geimpft war was
ist aber haltung dazu schreibt dass man
in die kommentare
ich starte einen neuen versuch mit
ungeimpften ins gespräch zu kommen und
hoffe vor testzentren in mainz jemanden
zu finden in deutschland gibt es
schließlich keine impfpflicht aber
häufig gilt die dreijährige bärin
restaurants theater oder hotels will
muss dann belegen dass er genesen
getestet oder geimpft ist andreas kommt
gerade vom testen er erzählt mir er habe
noch keinen vollständigen impfschutz
wurde bisher nur einmal geimpft das hat
er lange überlegt und ein mulmiges
gefühl dabei also meine eltern haben
auch aus dem grund das ist häufiger see
und meine eltern auch nicht mehr die
jüngsten sind und damit eine
risikogruppe sind derzeit einfach
sicherer für sie und deswegen habe ich
mich dazu entschieden aber wäre ich
jetzt nicht
so nah mit meinen eltern dann hätte es
heute nicht gemacht und warum nicht
kannst du das noch mal genau sagen
ich habe einfach richtig schlechtes
gefühl wie es gehandhabt wird ich mag es
überhaupt nicht wenn man so aus angst
dazu etwas getrieben wird durch drückt
und dann auch noch indirekt durch die
hintertür
mittlerweile gibt es auch zwei gehen das
heißt nur geimpfte oder genesene kommen
rein auch david ist nicht geimpft also
ich hätte mich schon impfen lassen wenn
ich hätt in die usa einreisen dürfen
aber das ging ja und zwar schon auch
ganz okay so k s gehört der nutzen
überwiegt nicht bisher das genau
also für mich zumindest ja okay und was
sagen sie leuten die sagen so
restaurantbesitzer vielleicht oder auch
studenten die sagen ey wir können nur so
wieder zurückkehren zu dem ganz normalen
leben wenn wir diese herdenimmunität
haben und das heißt nun mal dass sich
möglichst viele leute impfen lassen
müssen haben sie da verständnis für oder
ja das ist halt alles ansichtssache ja
was heißt jetzt ein jahr weniger vage
schmal so will bald ihre 75 bis 80
prozent erreicht haben es ist ja gut
aber bestehe jetzt unbedingt mitmachen
muss das ist halt die frage ob auch ohne
mich woher kommt die impfskepsis um
darauf eine antwort zu finden bin ich
zum interview mit kathrin schmelz
verabredet sie ist psychologin und
verhaltensökonomen seit beginn der
pandemie forscht sie zu dem thema
impfbereitschaft
ja wir sehen dass das vertrauen in die
regierung eine große rolle für die
impfbereitschaft spielt menschen die zum
beispiel zwischen dem ersten und dem
zweiten lockdown vertrauen in die
regierung verloren haben haben auch ihre
bereitschaft verloren und wir sehen auch
dass der glaube an die wirksamkeit der
impfung eine rolle spielt je mehr man
glaubt dass die impfung wirkt um die
pandemie zu beenden desto höher auch die
impfbereitschaft eine impfpflicht hält
sie für falsch also wir haben das von
beginn an gesehen in unseren umfragen
dass die freiwillige impfbereitschaft
deutlich höher lag als die bereitschaft
unter einer impfpflicht und das ist so
eine situation von reaktors oder
controller version wird es auch genannt
wenn man freiwillig von irgendwas
überzeugt dass dann macht man das anders
motiviert aber wenn man sich unter druck
gesetzt fühlt dann verliert man die lust
und möchte das nicht mehr machen und das
scheint bei der korona impfungen sehr
stark ausgeprägt zu sein ein versuch
mehr menschen zu überzeugen sind ins
aktionswochen dann gibt es zur impfung
mancherorts eine bratwurst beides ohne
termin trotzdem die zahl der täglich
verabreichten impfdosen dümpelt seit
september zwischen
250.000 und 300.000 damit es mehr werden
müsste mehr aufgeklärt werden sagt
psychologin kathrin schmelzer sie hat
festgestellt dass der anteil derjenigen
die eine impfung strikt ablehnen nur bei
fünf prozent liegt der rest ließe sich
überzeugen und genau wie im skepsis sei
auch in bereitschaft ansteckend ich
denke eine positive berichterstattung
über die impfbereitschaft kann viel
helfen denn wenn wir uns unsicher sind
dann orientieren wir uns am verhalten
anderer und diejenigen die sich unsicher
sind ob sie sich impfen lassen sollen
oder nicht impfen lassen sollen schauen
was machen die anderen und wenn sie
glauben dass nur 64 prozent der anderen
geimpft sind dann glauben sie gut ich
bin ein guter gesellschaft es geht
vielen anderen so die sehr skeptisch
sind so wie ich also mache ich das
erstmal nicht aber wenn man sich vor
augen hält dass wirklich acht von zehn
erwachsenen geimpft sind dann ist das
ein ganz anderes bild und kann so den
nachahmungseffekt in die positive
richtung mitziehen und ja dann hat man
das gefühl die impfung muss ja doch auch
wirklich was gutes sein wenn sich so
viele menschen freiwillig dafür
entscheiden ethikerin ruth baumann
hölzle schaut mit helikopter blick auf
die debatte und macht sich große sorgen
sie sagt der soziale frieden sein gefahr
wie können wir das verhindern norden
werden auf jeden fall bleiben weil das
geht schon viel zu tief und den anderen
menschen wieder aus menschen
wahrzunehmen nicht nur als
idee am anfang war es der andere mit
anderen meinungen dann war es plötzlich
der gegner jetzt ist das oft macht
erfahren das es zu bekämpfen gilt das
sind eskalationsstufen im verhalten
einer bevölkerung und da müssen wir
wirklich der eskalieren wenn wir nicht
wenn wir langfristig einfach weiter
friedlich mit einander zusammen leben
wollen und hierfür trägt natürlich die
politik eine immense vom toten meer alle
auch aus bürgerinnen und bürger und
diesbezüglich stellt sich dann immer die
frage wieweit interessiert mich mein
gegenüber und wie kann ich mit ihm in
eine beziehung kommen damit wird
wirklich von der sache her austauschen
können ohne einander wirklich zu
verurteilen sondern quasi aus quelle
auch wieder wahrzunehmen weil es ist ja
sehr einseitig und einem modul zu leben
war noch nie gesund
ihrer meinung nach ist niemand zu einer
impfung verpflichtet aber alle dazu sich
mit der option auseinanderzusetzen
das hat nicht nur mit respekt zu tun das
hat sogar mit der verpflichtung zu tun
das eigene handeln wenn ich so
kontrovers ist und eine sowie nennen da
sind derartig hohe eigentlich steve
gehabt dass ich begründen muss warum ich
mich so unter und das entscheide also
ich denke dass diese verpflichtung die
haben mir natürlich absolut denn klar
ist im moment kämpfen wir immer noch
alle gemeinsam gegen ein potenziell
tödliches virus hat man sich gegen
korona impfen lässt oder nicht das
entscheidet natürlich jede und jeder
selbst aber ich finde wichtig dass wenn
wir diese diskussion führen einander
zuhören und die sorgen und ängste der
gegenseite auch ernst nehmen wenn ihr
auf der suche seit nach informationen
zum thema impfung dann schaut man in die
beschreibung wir haben euch da ein paar
gute quellen verlinkt
[Musik]